Hoff's gum Roseman is beard pad welcome
back to five nights at Freddy's we are
on the third night on the third episode
that fits doesn't it hopefully we can do
a little better today cuz I've been
doing pretty badly all the episodes it's
just it's really hot god dammit he's
gonna call me I'll be one second blah
alright see how much see how much it
drains I'm pointing at it but you can't
see it but see how much it's draining
just from this a cupcake is laughing at
me I can feel it alright are they
alright well sides out where is the OSHA
I don't there she is
alright yeah she's still there man
that's great sounds like they're having
a great time out there
Oh Oh as I went to miss sing again where
did that batch go oh she's heading for
the restroom I won't blame her if she
needs to pee pee in the night oh she's
not there anymore oh she's in the
kitchen
I will fat [ __ ] gotta eat too oh it
looks like she's heading toward the east
Hall nice thong you got there oh she's
definitely heading here oh there oh
thank god
how did he just get back to designing I
guess she got her snack and with the
[ __ ] out oh my god I thought about that
damn I'm gonna leave no one broke up
missing again Oh
heading for the restrooms guess she has
a tiny barber barber bladder who gives a
[ __ ] EPS alert so they're right it's
2:00 a.m. I wish your time could go
faster oh my god it's so painfully slow
oh great she's just outside don't poop
on the floor now what huh you know the
rules
it's 3:00 a.m. oh no
oh she went back oh you look fabulous
what a great picture of you Oh sir you
look so good I will never trust a mascot
ever again in my life after this [ __ ]
game oh she's back in there outside
great
oh she moved again holy [ __ ] can you
stop moving please
where the [ __ ] they should go now oh
okay it's 4:00 a.m. come on we have
plenty of batteries - oh my god don't
don't call high before you cross the
road come on brows big nerd she's in the
kitchen now oh god they're all out there
[ __ ] all out how did this happen
they're all out I don't know where the
other one is I'm just gonna pretend that
there's two of them
no all sigh Oh somewhere did you go also
I get a [ __ ] life it's 5:00 a.m. 7
a.m. waking up in the morning gotta be
fresh gotta go [ __ ] off the roof outside
I wanna play this game anymore come on
we don't have much left please ok what's
the mood thank God
what about what about Reuben Reuben get
alive
I'm never gonna date you special if you
act like this reven god damn it stop
[ __ ] creeping out Oh goddamn it will
say sout again oh my god it was sad that
horny [ __ ] sorry I said it all says
they're okay but where's Ruben can
Reuben back the [ __ ] off four percent
battery bro bed Oh
oh the fist is penetrator disguise oh
that feels good
ah high five [ __ ] breasts am fourth
night oh my god ah I feel like a sack of
potatoes all right we'll listen to him
this time
hello oh yeah
tell me
[ __ ] was that what's banging Oh God
thank you
check outside those sins
stop banging please Oh God
what is that what is that
Oh sake man look at much battery I'd
ring Oh God Reuben
Steve Steve Davis Quebec goddamn Steve
well you both know it wasn't gonna work
out here we are again my little friends
who's the bear or great they're both odd
and the bear is looking at me hello Paul
says in the kitchen Steve is pooping and
Reuben is a [ __ ]
great huh oh the bear is gone where the
[ __ ] is the bear the virus is there to
[ __ ] me when my hair is behind my chair
what happen if the [ __ ] the game just
tapped out I'm still alive I don't know
how I still eleven and barely breathe
shut up shut the [ __ ] up oh that sounds
wonderful in there wish I could join the
party see what the [ __ ] is she doing in
that kitchen
[ __ ] humping all the plates I need to
get to 3 a.m. before the matter goes to
50 oh that's oh that's just wonderful
route Reuben are you doing that
oh god I [ __ ] up now oh god I'm so
scared every time I put it down I'm like
oh boy oh my god half there halfway
there
this is like torture this game it's
[ __ ] torture hey friend Oh
oh my god ah it's [ __ ] game but I
ChaCha's this [ __ ] game this is not
for me man it is not for me what am i
doing with my life
Rose what is what are we doing here ah
why do I have to go through this torment
and pain and boring gameplay let's be
honest it's pretty dull well I guess it
is continuous [ __ ] angles oh sorry I
it starts off like a really easy for the
first five minutes and then by they're
all in your pants what do you do I don't
know you can't answer me anyway but
please tell me how you did today you
know the thing that you had to do mm-hmm
that is a long weird but I'm okay with
it what is what is up with the teddy
can someone explain that the teddy he's
obviously the main guy but I won't stain
I don't live that diet it's my jaw look
we're don't I do this I don't know what
I don't know oh god dammit oh well sides
out maybe he's pissed off that he
doesn't have a name we'll call him titty
assessing the kitchen everything is that
you should be oh they're both missing
that's just fun [ __ ] tastic what is
he doing stop it
No bad ulcer where's Ruben
stop it you're not a demon Alyssa you
may be ugly like one but I know you are
not one
[ __ ] off Ruben I'm not gonna date you or
all stuff for that matter really both
idiots at the same time how am I
supposed to deal with this what is he
doing in the female restroom titty
I need all Sicily to get the [ __ ] out
cuz she's draining all my [ __ ]
battery is that right cupcake that's
Mandy no you're not supposed to say like
that AUSA what's that you [ __ ] [ __ ]
thank you thank you
we stole my battery what [ __ ] this job
[ __ ] Steve Jobs no don't
I like him oh god these noises I can't
see I can't see mobs it's all connected
isn't it
okay we got this route at Joe's we
[ __ ] got this it needs to hit 4:00
a.m. before my battery hits 33 otherwise
I'm dead oh god I think Reuben sat on my
ass yep
[ __ ] oh god where we're using too much
power this is not good this is not good
this very very tiny chance that we can
do this Oh God
good pawn you take the field rune up to
one more here we are again in this tiny
[ __ ] hellhole aren't you happy this
game with the oculus I would literally
[ __ ] my [ __ ] pants not exaggerating I
would really just wear a diaper playing
this end oh oh how nice
not today [ __ ] oh oh that was close oh
he's back where's Ruben though oh god no
oh this [ __ ] game oh god what's this
missing
no I'm dead why me oh no I'm not gonna
touch anything why would I touch
anything if I'm just gonna die anyway I
mean
uh-huh that's why that's why oh my god
final tempura we can do this honey I I
react you slowly oh my god I'm sucking
so much ass right now I updated the game
I hope it's not as hard I don't know
it's probably it's too hard this game
and I maybe I'm bad but for me it's very
hard to play this game I tried so hard
to stock the teddy bears I wish I had a
shotgun at least give me a shotgun Miss
America god damn what they switch places
goddamn it I got tapped out again why
does that keep happening this is just
not my game apparently what what was
that does random in to kill know you
know you know what you know what you
know I [ __ ] this game I'm never gonna
play it again
that's this [ __ ] [ __ ] alright
breasts gonna half during that episode
there then but I hope you enjoyed anyway
sorry for talking so much that's what
she said as always we're gonna end it
with the brofist thanks for hanging out
with me today as always stay awesome
roof